The Joe Rogan experience. When will it
snap back? I mean it's coming. Trump.
That's what Trump's press. What
that is. He's Gunna win again.
He's going to win again or the WHO can
beat him. They're not going to beat it.
There's no one who can write.
He's going to win again.
He's going to win again
because of shit like this.
The more shit like this happens.
There's a then what's after chunk down.
Then there's another four
years son Donald Jr Donald J.
Donald Jr was a with a
friend of a friend of mine.
His name is crispy and he,
he's a disabled veteran or a shit.
He's very able, I should say, but he's
a wounded veteran. He's, he was missing,
he had his leg amputated,
Burns over most of his body.
Super positive attitude. Great Guy.
Anyways, he doesn't get political online.
He took a picture with
Donald Trump jr right,
and Instagram took it down for
violating their terms of service.
It's just a photo picture of just
photo with hesitant son. Yeah.
Photo with him at Trump jr standing
there and they took the picture down.
What that, what are you doing? Yeah,
maybe that's say hitch. Did they ever,
when they do that that it gives you a
reason or they just do what they want?
Well, he posted it on his, he sent
me a direct message about it too.
I asked,
I actually reached out to him,
cause a on follow him and he follows me
and I was like, this is this shit real.
And he's like, Yup. And he's
super positive about it.
I mean this is the guy who served our
country too and he's, he's a great guy.
Like his, his, his, his, his uh,
Instagram handle is
crispy 11 B. Okay. Yeah.
And he just put it up there and they said
that they got him for terms of service
and they took it down and he put it
back up again. Good. Good for him.
So this is the photo right here.
I'm going to say when asked to Instagram
says that they didn't do it so they
didn't do it, but who took
it down that said, however,
an Instagram spoke
first and told Fox News.
The post was reviewed but was not deleted
by the company after I found the post
did not violate their standards.
But that's not true because it's missing.
Spokesperson said that there are a number
of reasons at post may no longer be
available, including the account holder
deletes either the account or the post.
He's saying he didn't do that, so it
could have been something else. Mm.
I mean you can't prove
it. Yeah. I don't know.
Well this dude is not an attention whore.
You wouldn't do that.
He wouldn't do that in lie about it.
That's ridiculous. I mean, Twitter,
Instagram could be lying and I just
never really could be a glitch too. Yeah.
You know,
sometimes it's a for two at as glitch.
That looks like a massive conspiracy.
Yeah, but he said they'd send them notice.
It said it violated the terms of
services. So if he said that, okay. Yeah,
that's what was said back to me.
Pretty sure that's the screenshot you'll
want to make sure that's what he says.
You violated something. Yeah.
That's what you want. I mean,
it's just so weird what's going on now.
This is,
everything just seemed so
fucking preposterous. Yeah.
Just like on Facebook, Twitter,
all that stuff. If I get,
if it's something negative, I just, you
know, that's gone. I don't, I don't let,
I don't let people just start bashing me
on that stuff. I just, okay, here it is.
Once I landed,
I opened up Instagram and got a message
that your post was taken down for
violating Instagram guidelines,
so yeah.
Did he post that? Yes, he did.
Oh, there you go. Wait a minute.
Let me see what it did.
Yeah,
yeah. He posted a thing saying it.
Okay. Here's what he posted. Yeah.
It said wounded veteran violated
community standards by posting with Donald
Trump jr he didn't post
the actual notification,
but he probably didn't even
save it. Right. Why would you,
yeah. He's, I believe him.
I believe him. I just somebody,
you're right. It is a sad,
I think you also have overzealous
employees. I think there's that too. Yeah.
I think there's probably a huge company.
Yeah. I mean, you, anybody can go row,
get a minute and just do what the
what the what the where they want.
You think the reading Dick Pics and kind
of just been fucking with them on the
other way.
The other way around.
Someone could've just flagged
it via a bunch of bots.
It's just made up disappear. Oh right.
To get a reaction like this. Yeah.
That's all. It could be simple
as that. Can you do that? Sure.
So if you just had a bot to do it right,
I could do it right now.
Instagram review it manually
before they delete it. No,
cause I can just be taken down.
It happens on other accounts for that
doesn't get reviewed that way and it just
got taken down because it got
flagged so many times. I don't know.